being a comedian and having disability I
didn't find many challenges with work
being someone who dreams on TV being
someone who is a writer being someone
who is an actress I feel like
entertainment and broadcast news ignore
the fact that a DA also applies to them
this was signed 25 years ago and most
workplaces still ignore its existence
they still think that accommodating is
an option because of the word reasonable
accommodations and I work with people
with disabilities who are in their 20s
and 30s or they're just graduating
college and they're terrified for the
person interviewing them to know they
have a disability they're trying so hard
to get through the process and pass as
able that's not the world that we should
live in at all and that is the reality
for so many people if you turn on the TV
we're invisible
we're not present on daytime talk shows
panel shows soap operas morning news
shows we're not the anchors were not the
hosts
we're not even guest co-hosts and I was
watching a very famous cable news woman
who's known for her intersectionality
she said live on television
we cannot invite wheelchair users into
the studio because our studio is not
accessible I had been in that studio it
was built two years ago why are they
still building studios that are not
accessible in this day and age why
because we're not thought of
we're not thought of when people talk
about diversity they're not talking
about people with disabilities they're
not we've been completely run over in
the intersection of intersectionality
you would think since we're the largest
minority that everyone bumps into at
least one disabled people and they know
disabled people guess what that's not
the reality I don't know how I don't
know
but I've had people tell me you know he
never saw anyone like you before and I
think it comes back to storybooks to
television to really actively making
sure that it's not one character for one
episode in a wheelchair that disappears
the next day look at Sesame Street when
I was growing up
Sesame Street had a deaf woman that
changed my perception she was part of
this normal world that has Muppets
but like this world that I was so
accustomed to just like old people like
mr. Hooper who died and taught me what
death was and those images are gone so
there's a couple of characters that do
have disabilities sprinkled throughout
children's television but it's not
something that you're seeing often
enough